bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat hier les sénateurs ont adopté le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
pour 2009
le vote de ce collectif budgétaire a été
marquée par l'adoption contre l'avis du
gouvernement de l'amendement déposé par
le président centriste de la commission
des finances jean arthuis
cet amendement propose d'encadrer les
rémunérations des dirigeants
d'entreprises aidées par l'état mais
également de supprimer les stock options
et actions gratuites
cet amendement est très proche du décret
promulgué par le gouvernement lundi mais
pour le président de la commission des
finances qui a été soumis hier par les
socialistes et les communistes
il était impératif que le sénat ne se
contente pas d'un décret et que le
parlement fixe la règle
je vous propose donc ce matin de revoir
cette discussion bonne science à tous
sur public sénat nous en arrivons
l'article sur article11 j'ai une demande
de prise de parole de monsieur thierry
foucaud oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le moins que l'on puisse dire est que
l'actualité la plus récente donne à la
discussion de cet article 11 relief tout
particulier au départ nous étions fasse
un article portant sur les conventions
passées entre l'état et les
établissements de crédit et ceci dans le
droit fil de la loi de finances
rectificative d'octobre et du plan de
sauvetage des banques
il s'agissait il s'agit toujours de
mettre en évidence la nécessité d'une
plus grande transparence des flux
financiers dans chaque établissement
notamment au regard de ce que l'on
appelle les états non coopératifs
parce que dans le contexte de crise
économique et financière globale
on vient de découvrir que
nos établissements de crédit aux
dirigeants parfait aux dirigeants
parfaitement respectable et d'ailleurs
respecté avait pris la mauvaise habitude
de domicilier des fonds des comptes et
des crédits dans des paradis fiscaux des
paradis fiscaux auxquels on demande
aujourd'hui plus de propres de
transparence donc ce qui revient à
demander entre auto filiale de la
société générale domicilié à jersey ou à
celle de paris basse ayant pignon sur
rue à monaco sans parler des îles cayman
centre ici par exemple d'être plus
coopératif sur la réalité des mouvements
financiers opérés à leur guichet il
serait faut-il le reconnaître pour le
moins étonnant que l'argent public coule
à flots pour nos banquiers et viennent
échouer sur les rillons j'dirais
arrivage de guernesey ou alors du lac
léman
et de fait se poser la question de la
rémunération des dirigeants de cette île
deux établissements de crédit depuis il
y a eu la faire ou des à boutons la
sphère de la rupture totalement
défiscalisé de thierry morin l'a fait
la sphère de la retraite chapeau de
daniel bouton qui est devenu donc
récidivistes tandis qu'on soupçonne elf
michelin et adidas de fraude fiscale
dissimulé à l'ombre du palais princier
de vaduz et notre collègue jean arthuis
président de la commission des finances
qui a déposé un amendement de réécriture
de l'arctique qui va dans les faits
c'est vrai au delà du texte initial de
l'article 11 qui s'adressait à quelque
chose comme six établissements de crédit
alors bien sûr
cet amendement va bien au delà va au
delà en reprenant une partie du fameux
décret relatif aux entreprises aidées
par l'état et dont le gouvernement
entend faire la clôture de controverses
ou de la controverse sur la rémunération
des dirigeants d'entreprise
mais ce que nous souhaitions dire à ce
moment au moment de l'intervention sur
l'arctique le 11
comme nous allons le voir le compte n'y
est pas tout à fait c'est ce que nous
comptions précisé à cet instant un de la
discussion ou du commencement de la
discussion de cet article 11
merci monsieur fuku trois amendements
discussion commune plus précisément un
amendement et deux sous amendement
l'amendement 60 80 qui frise la parole
et à jean arthuis ce monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
l amendement que je propose au sénat ce
soir a pour objet de veiller à ce que
l'argent public l'argent des
contribuables ne puisse pas participer
au financement de rémunérations que nous
pourrions considérées comme abusives de
versement de bonus exceptionnels
d'indemnités de départ dont les montants
atteignent parfois des sommets
il a pour objet aussi de veiller à ce qu
en cette période de crise alors que le
cours des actions est au plus bas et et
ne risque sans doute pas de descendre
encore beaucoup de permettre
l'attribution de stock options ou
d'actions gratuites au profit des
dirigeants et des mandataires sociaux
d'entreprises qui bénéficient
momentanément compte tenu de la
situation de crise exceptionnelle que
nous traversons dead de l'état nos
collègues députés ont pris l'initiative
de cet article
on songe dont l'objet dans la rédaction
qui nous vient de l'assemblée nationale
se limitent invité le gouvernement à
compléter
les conventions telles qu'elles ont été
prévus dans la loi de finances
rectificative du 16 octobre 2008 et
celle qui prévoit la création de la
société de prise de participation de
l'état et de la société de financement
de l'économie française
nos collègues députés expriment le
souhait est que l'on tienne compte en
effet des relations qui peuvent exister
entre ces banques bénéficiaires des
aides de l'état et ces paradis fiscaux
plus précisément ces territoires où ses
états non coopératifs et qui persistent
à s'opposer à la levée du secret
bancaire
je pense que nos collègues députés ont
raison d'avancer dans cette voie
puis je rappeler que le groupe de
travail constitué à l'initiative des
présidents du sénat et de l'assemblée
nationale composée de douze sénateurs
est de 12 députés ont procédé à un
diagnostic partagé ont formulé des
propositions qu'ils ont remise au
président de la république à la veille
du g20 de novembre 2008
nous avons également mise à jour ce
document que nous avons remis au
président de la république lundi dernier
est la première de nos préoccupations de
nos préoccupations
essai de nos préconisations c'est de
lutter contre les paradis fiscaux par
conséquent ce qu'ont prévu nos collègues
députés et bienvenue c'est la raison
pour laquelle je reprends cette
disposition dans la réécriture de
l'article 11 que je vous propose
mais j'y ajoute deux dispositions c'est
de prévoir dans quelles conditions sont
à louer les rémunérations
exceptionnelles
les bonus les indemnités éventuelles de
licenciement aux dirigeants et
mandataires sociaux de ces entreprises
bénéficiaires de l'aide de l'état dans
le cadre de la crise et je prévois
également de prohiber la distribution
d'actions gratuites et de stock options
aux mêmes dirigeants et mandataires
sociaux
pour être plus précis je précise le
champ des attributions d'être des canaux
de l'aide
c'est à dire les fonds qui
proviendraient des prêts de l'état
consentie directement des garanties de
l'état à l'occasion d'un prêt ou dans
lesquels l'état aurait investi les
sociétés auxquelles la société de
financement de l'économie française a
consenti un prêt les sociétés dont les
émissions de titres financiers ont été
souscrites par la société de prise de
participation de l'état il peut s'agir
d'actions de préférence il peut s'agir
de titres super subordonnés il peut
s'agir enfin deux sociétés dans
lesquelles le fonds stratégique
d'investissement a directement ou
indirectement investi tel est donc
l'objet de cet amendement bien sûr le
gouvernement a promulgué hier matin un
décret qui reprend l'essentiel des
dispositions que vous proposent
l'amendement que je viens de vous
présenter je me dois toutefois de
préciser que ce décret vise les six
organismes bancaires qui ont bénéficié
des apports de la société de prise de
participation de l'état et les
constructeurs automobiles autrement dit
ne sont pas prises en compte les sous
traitants de l'automobile dans ce projet
de loi de finances rectificative nous
tirons les conséquences d'un pacte
automobile qui prévoit des dispositions
dead financière à nombre d'entreprises
pas seulement les constructeurs
automobiles
donc cet amendement s'efforce de couvrir
un chant appropriées afin de veiller à
ce que les fonds publics
l'argent des contribuables ne participe
pas à des financements des rémunérations
exceptionnelles nous sommes dans un
cadre de crise
nous voulons le respect de ces bonnes
pratiques de gouvernance d'entreprise
tel est l'objet de l'amendement que je
vous propose
merci chers collègues deux sous un
moment à cet amendement
74 rectifié bis sous-amendement 110 et
111 monsieur gérard chers collègues ce
que vous pouvez nous les présenter oui
merci monsieur le président par
commodité je présenterai devenir commune
les deux sous un monde comme vient de
l'indiquer le président jean arthuis le
texte de l'amendement 74 déjà été
rectifié son champ d'application
relativement élargi en effet alors que
l'article 11 de prévoyait de
s'intéresser qu'à la situation des
établissements de crédit voici qu'au
terme de du rectificatif les entreprises
du secteur automobile et celles
bénéficiant des aides directes ou
indirectes du fonds stratégique
d'investissement sont concernés par le
principe de suspension de la
distribution de stock options et
d'actions gratuites prévues moratoire
donc sur les stock options mais
maintient il faut le souligner d autres
éléments variables de rémunération ou
encore des conventions particulières
visant notamment à permettre à quelques
dirigeants d'entreprises de bénéficier
d'un confortables parachutes dorés ou
d'un prêt personnel à taux privilégiés
destiné à tout usage par le souscripteur
dans la pratique pour le donner qu'un
exemple une banque peut aujourd'hui
continuait d'attribuer à l'un de ses
dirigeants un prêt à faible taux
d'intérêt près dont il peut par exemple
profiter pour acquérir des actions de sa
propre entreprise au moment même où le
cours de l'action s'avère déprimé
toutefois
le texte de l'amendement du président de
la commission des finances appellent
quelques observations supplémentaires
nous avons comme chacun d'entre vous
regardé avec intérêt le texte du décret
promulgué hier au journal officiel et en
particulier la fin de l'article 2 qui
précise je cite les conventions
prévoient que les éléments variables de
la rémunération mentionnés au 2 ne sont
pas attribués ou versée si la situation
de l'entreprise l'a conduit à procéder à
des licenciements de forte ampleur
hors ces éléments du texte du décret ne
figure pas pour le moment dans
l'amendement du président arthuis il
nous semble qu'il soit très difficile de
voter aujourd'hui
l'amendement 74 en faisant d'un article
de loi
un élément législatives de moindre
portée que le décret qu'il est censé
remplacer
nous proposons donc l'attribution des
stock options et actions gratuites soit
effectivement suspendus dans les
entreprises visées par l'amendement et
procédant à des licenciements
économiques ou à des plans de
restructuration c'est là donc le sens du
sous-amendement 110 notre
sous-amendement 111 porte lui sur la
question des autres entreprises
là où rien n'est encore prévu en tout
cas pas dans le décret encore que le
fait que nombre d'entreprises soit à la
fois largement bénéficiaires des aides
publiques constitue la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires ou les
allègements de cotisations sociales
pourrait lui-même justifier de tels
diffuser de telles dispositions
nous proposons donc que les comités
d'entreprise soit informée comme cela
est déjà le cas dans d'autres procédures
de la passation de convention entre
dirigeants salariés et conseil
d'administration et sur la mise en
oeuvre des plans de stock ce stock
options et de distribution d actions
gratuites
merci anciens collègues nationaux
rapporteur général
l'avis de la commission sur l'amendement
et les deux sous un monde
je vais d'abord commenté les deux sous
amendement si vous le voulez bien je
serai très bref sur le sens qui reprend
une disposition qui a été mise en
discussion dans la proposition de loi
débattue la semaine dernière est
repoussé et la commission des finances
ne peut naturellement que réaffirmer son
opposition à cette proposition
s'agissant du numéro 110 le texte de
l'amendement me semble inopérant et peu
claire il insère un alinéa au sein du
grand 2 qui ne fait référence à aucune
convention
par conséquent la mention convention
dans l'amendement ne permet pas de
connaître la cible de l'amendement
ceci doit s'expliquer par le fait que
vous avez repris dans votre texte
une phrase du décret qui sincères mal
dans l'amendement préparé par le
président a redit en tout état de cause
ce décret publié hier est relatif aux
conditions de rémunération des
dirigeants des entreprises aidées par
l'état ou bénéficiant du soutien de
l'état du fait de la crise économique et
des responsables d'entreprises publiques
précise
j'ouvre les guillemets les conventions
prévues par le décret prévoit que les
éléments variables de la rémunération ne
sont pas attribués ou versée si la
situation de l'entreprise l'a conduit à
procéder à des licenciements de forte
ampleur
donc je pense que de ce point de vue
votre amendement est au moins
partiellement satisfait ses remarques
conjuguer me conduisent à exprimer un
avis défavorable sur le sous-amendement
numéro 110 alors j'en viens à
l'amendement numéro rectifier j'observe
que de même que le décret il se situe
clairement dans le contexte de la crise
et ses effets
son corner dans le temps en second lieu
de même que le décret ce dispositif
précise une conditionnalité pour les
aides publiques qui sont apportées
notamment dans le secteur bancaire et
dans le secteur automobile
et c'est un raisonnement auquel
naturellement on ne peut pas ne pas
adhérer le champ couvert par
l'amendement arthuis est très voisin de
celui du décret il ya quelques variantes
est le peuvent s'expliquer et mais tout
ceci ne me paraît pas essentiel
cependant je relève que l'interdiction
en cas de licenciements de forte ampleur
figure dans le décret et ne figure pas
dans l'amendement arthuis dans la
rédaction qui nous est présente mais
l'essentiel est peut-être de savoir s'il
est absolument indispensable de
légiférer pour confirmer dans le droit
positif ce qui a déjà été fait par le
pouvoir réglementaire grâce au décret
qui a été publié hier finalement mes
chers collègues
sachant que les dispositions sont des
dispositions très voisines
la question que nous avons arbitré et
celle là est ce que le décret autonome
que le pouvoir réglementaire
à mon sens est parfaitement en droit de
prendre se suffit à lui-même
est ce qu'il convient de lui apporter
plus de solennité par une insertion dans
la législation je crois que c'est la
seule question qu'il nous appartient de
trancher à cette heure ci
je rappelle par souci de précision
notariale bien qu'alain lambert ne sont
pas parfaits mais nous ce soir
que la commission des finances dans sa
majorité n'a pas voté cet amendement
mais qui nous avait été présenté dans un
texte et qui a été quelque peu
perfectionner depuis voilà mes chers
collègues ce que je puis dire pour
rendre compte de l'analyse qui a été
faite de l'amendement arthuis ainsi que
des deux sous amendements qui ont été
présentés merci le sauna votre général
monsieur ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs sur
les deux sous-amendement sur
l'amendement 111
nous en avons déjà discuté de cette de
cet amendement est donc l'avis du
gouvernement est négative comme il
l'était déjà tout à l'heure sur
l'amendement numéro 110 je pense que
l'amendement est satisfait en réalité
par le décret qui était pris par le
gouvernement il y a quelques jours c'est
à dire hier en fait hier matin cet
amendement est satisfait parce qu'il
interdit de verser des rémunérations
variables
si la société procède à des
licenciements de forte ampleur donc
c'est à peu près ce que vous dites
en termes un tout petit peu différent
mais c'est bien votre état d'esprit donc
je pense qu'il est satisfait à ce titre
je considère qu'ils pourraient être au
moins retirer sinon j'appellerais un
vote contre mais je le président arthuis
l'amendement que vous fait l'amendement
que vous présenter et partager dans son
objectif par le gouvernement nous
partageons la même idée de justice
sociale dans cette période de crise et
le gouvernement partage évidemment les
préoccupations qui sont celles au delà
nos différences politiques qui
s'expriment sur l'ensemble de ces de ces
bancs pour que les rémunérations
excessives sous quelque forme que ce
soit qui sont parfois versées à des
dirigeants des mandataires sociaux dans
des conditions qui sont des conditions
que ne peut pas supporter l'opinion
publique que ces rémunérations doivent
être combattus et donc interdites ou
réglementé
selon les cas de figure et vous avez
noté monsieur le président a depuis que
le gouvernement a réagi rapidement à ce
débat qui a eu lieu très profondément un
peu partout dans les médias dans
l'opinion publique
entre les uns et les autres il beaucoup
beaucoup de débats ce débat a été vif ce
débat a été très très profond il est
allé au fond des choses
le gouvernement a décidé d'agir très
rapidement et le gouvernement a publié à
publier l'un décret qui porte le numéro
2009 348 et ils aient été publiés d'une
façon très très clair qu'est ce qui dit
ce décret il dit au fond monsieur le
président ce que ce que vous dites dans
votre propre amendement
donc on est dans un débat un peu un peu
étonnant en réalité puisque la mesure
est déjà en application ce qui devrait
vous donner satisfaction puisque vous
avez évidemment beaucoup contribué sur
le fond à cette à ces mesures il dit
l'interdiction d'attribuer des stock
options et des actions gratuites aux
dirigeants des entreprises aidées par l
etat s obtiennent un soutien
exceptionnel pendant la crise
interdiction de verser des rémunérations
variables
quand elles ne sont pas la contrepartie
de performances réelles et le décret
précise qu'il ne peut pas s'agir de
performance boursière
c'est vraiment cela qui a choqué c'est
une performance boursière a souvent en
réalité finalement assez peu à voir avec
la performance économique elle même de
l'entreprise est soumise à d'autres à
d'autres tensions interdiction de verser
des rémunérations variables
si l'entreprise procède ce que je viens
de dire à des licenciements de forte
ampleur
donc nous devions réagir vite parce
qu'il fallait mettre un terme à ce débat
dans l'opinion publique on peut pas
laisser prospérer des débats qui donne
le sentiment aux français qu'il ya de
l'injustice dans les décisions qui sont
prises elles nous l'avons donc fait très
vite
le gouvernement a donc très vite indiqué
qu'elles étaient les règles du jeu et
indiqué qu'il ne tolérerait aucun écart
de comportement je pense que la parole
politique a été forte et le texte qui a
été pris et un texte fort
votre amendement est donc
encore une fois je le dit satisfait en
réalité c'est donc un débat de deux
formes que nous avons mais en aucun cas
un débat de fond et ça poserait un
certain nombre de difficultés si le
sénat venait à voter votre amendement
d'abord parce qu'il renvoie au fond un
décret en conseil d'état
et c'est une procédure particulièrement
longue ça veut dire que mon père grosso
modo un mois dans la procédure parce que
il y a des délais notamment de
promulgation de la loi et après via
l'analyse en conseil d'état
alors que nous sommes sur le même sujet
pour prendre les mêmes décisions sur les
mettre dans la même situation sur
pourquoi attendre un mois de plus
difficile à expliquer à l'opinion
publique
et si votre amendement était votée on se
retrouverait dans une situation quelque
peu inconfortable où la loi en fait
renverrait un décret qui se trouve déjà
en application
moi la situation un peu aussi étonnante
dans ces conditions je le président
arthuis moi je vous demande de retirer
votre amendement puisque le gouvernement
a choisi la voie réglementaire pour
contester ce choix mais c'était un choix
en réalité qui était un choix lié à la
puissance de la demande à la puissance
de demande de l'opinion publique et peu
de beaucoup de parlementaires qui sont
ici monsieur le président de raincourt
beaucoup de parlementaires qui sont ici
nous ont demandé d'agir au plus vite de
ne pas laisser la situation un peu
dérivé dérapé pour rire même on ne
pouvait pas se permettre de cela et la
parole politique devait être très fortes
notamment de la part de chaud qui avait
pris les décisions et notamment le
gouvernement grâce au parlement pris des
décisions d'aider ces entreprises au
fond à à tenir face à la crise et donc
il fallait évidemment très vite préciser
les choses et c'est pour ça que cette
voie a été choisi parce que c'est la
plus rapide
on est dans une crise on va pas se poser
la question de savoir si ça doit être la
loi ou si ça doit être le règlement si
juridiquement ça peut être le règlement
est là c'est bien le cas alors
choisissons la voie la plus rapide parce
que c'est la voie qu'attendent les
français c'est pour ça que nous avons
hachey comme cela donc c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire monsieur le président
je suis le mieux serait que après avoir
finalement encore une fois a déclenché
ce débat mais c'est tant mieux sur la
forme que vous puissiez retirer votre
amendement
et puis faire en sorte que le décret
puisse s'appliquer d'une façon apaisée
finalement et cela dès maintenant
puisqu'il est en application aujourd'hui
plutôt que de retarder au fond des
décisions que les français ne
supporteraient pas devoir retarder
merci messieurs les politiques sont
devenus madame nicole bricq puis gérard
longuet depuis le mois d'octobre dernier
à trois reprises
le groupe socialiste a défendu des
propositions notamment de nature fiscale
visant à encadrer les rémunérations des
dirigeants et des mandataires sociaux
nous l'avons fait d après la loi de
finances rectificative qui accorder des
aides soit en fonds propres soit en
garantie des aides de l'état aux banques
là on fait le 4 novembre au travers
notre proposition de loi nous l'avons
fait jeudi dernier en soutenant nos
amendements et en votant la proposition
de loi du groupe crc et nous l'avons
fait avant-hier lors de la discussion
générale et en défendant avant l'article
1 toute une série d'amendements qui
visait à la fois à réformer la
gouvernance d'entreprise et à encadrer
ces rémunérations
et comme
nous le disions jeudi dernier le
secrétaire général de l'elysée avait
annoncé un décret qui devait avoir
l'avantagé d'être facile et rapide
plutôt que de choisir la voie
parlementaire
et quand nous regardons le décret et
j'avoue que plus je le regarde plus je
trouve d'une part que son périmètre est
extrêmement limité que le renvoi qu'il
fait aux critères de performance dont on
n'habite pas bien compris lesquelles il
était le fait que l'on confié au conseil
d'administration d'établir ces critères
de performance
le fait que peut pas de sanction était
prévu pour le non respect en fait plus
nous le regardons plus il est
insatisfaisant et notamment au regard de
la tante de l'opinion qui a été révélé
je dois le dire y compris par quand on
interroge les lecteurs du figaro 80 % se
déclarent non seulement choquée mais
sont partisans de la manière forte et
notamment de la manière législatives
alors le président puis enfin le notre
collègue sénateur arthuis
excusez moi nous a présenté un
amendement qu'il a rectifié depuis et
j'ai effectivement comparer son
amendement et le décret et je constate
en toute objectivité nous constatons que
il est très en retrait il est même pas
du tout à la première marche de tout ce
que nous avons proposé mais par rapport
au décret il a quand même deux ou trois
éléments qui vont plus loin
outre mais je vais j'y reviendrai dans
ma conclusion le fait qu'il est de
nature législative
il est temps la mesure aux dirigeants et
aux mandataires sociaux
les dirigeants un dirigeant c'est
quelqu'un qui participe aux décisions
stratégiques
c'est les ce sont les membres du comité
exécutif
ça m'apparaît clair il est en quelque
peu le périmètre dans la mesure où il
précise notamment que les entreprises
qui bénéficieraient du fonds stratégique
d'investissement directement ou
indirectement et bien son conte sont
concernés par par l'âme les mesures qui
sont proposés et il fait une référence
explicite à la révision des conventions
qui ont pu être signés avec l'état dans
le cadre à la suite de la loi de
finances rectificative donc il marque un
progrès extrêmement léger qui ne comble
pas notre attente c'est clair mais il a
quand même cet amendement un énorme
avantage
et c'est là que je voudrais terminer
dans la discussion générale
nous avons dit que il était d'une
certaine manière une très vilaine
manière que faisait le gouvernement et
qu'il fallait sauver l'honneur du
parlement et au moment où nos collègues
députés de tous les groupes dans le
cadre de la mission d'information
constituée sous la houlette de monsieur
philippe houillon début une députée ump
ont remis aujourd'hui un rapport d'étape
de cette mission sur les rémunérations
des dirigeants qui très clairement en
appel à la loi nous sénateurs nous
serions en retrait par rapport à nos
collègues députés en nous en remettant à
un décret nous croyons que la loi est
essentielle dans cette affaire est que
si vous voulez utiliser comme vous venez
encore de le faire
l'argument de la rapidité je veux une
fois encore démontré qu'il n'est pas
fondée parce que vous avez eu l'occasion
si vous vouliez être rapide le président
de la république a fustigé ces
rémunérations et notamment les bonus en
septembre dans son discours de toulon
eh bien vous pouviez dès le mois
d'octobre dans la loi de finances
rectificative que vous avez proposé au
vote du parlement
vous pouviez inscrire à l'article 6 des
précisions concernant ce que vous
attendiez des conventions qui seraient
signés par les entreprises qui auraient
l'aide de l'état vous pouviez le faire
vous pouviez le faire aussi à l'occasion
de la deuxième loi de finances
rectificative de décembre
vous pouviez le faire à l'occasion de la
loi de finances initiale pour 2009 et
vous pouviez encore le faire à
l'occasion de la première loi de
finances rectificative pour 2009
les précisément au moment si ça qui est
très choquant au moment où nous avons un
véhicule législatif idoine cette loi de
finances rectificative secrétaire
général de l'elysée se permet de dire
jeudi dernier nous faisons un degré
parce que c'est plus facile et plus
rapide
autant dire que l'exécutif s'assoit sur
le parlement et ça c'est pas acceptable
ce n'est pas acceptable donc il faut le
faire ce soir
alors évidemment je vais pas vous dire
que l'amendement de notre collègue
arthuis est extraordinaire je viens de
vous démontrer qu'il ne l'était pas mais
si nous voulons que ce débat reste dans
les mains du parlement que cet
amendement aille jusque à la commission
mixte paritaire et que avec les députés
avec nos collègues députés nous en
débattions il faut que ce soir on soit
clair sur cette affaire il ne serait ce
que pour cet argument eh bien il faut
effectivement que le sénat se prononce
et que la loi dise ce qu'elle veut parce
que autrement eh bien moi je regrette
mais ça veut dire que finalement on
donne acte à l'exécutif
tout ça pour que dans la stratégie de
communication qui est saine
gouvernement et de et de l'elysée eh
bien on puisse dire
avez vous voyez il ya un problème le
président et les réactifs et ben nous on
ne marche pas dans cette affaire on ne
marche pas dans cette opération de
communication et nous voulons que ce
soit la loi qui se prononcent pour
explications de gérard longuet
oui monsieur le président sur le
ministre chaque collègue
j'écoutais à l'instant madame briques
avec beaucoup d'attention et je
comprends son raisonnement sur le fond
je partage naturellement l'émotion de
nos compatriotes qui a abouti à cette
proposition d'amendement que nous
présente jean arthuis des jeux rappelle
en effet l'intervention manu mme bricq
ce sentiment d'une course de vitesse
la vérité c'est que l'on ne peut pas
diriger des entreprises même en période
de crise fût ce avec le soutien de
l'état par la voie réglementaire ou par
la voie législative avec la plasticité
suffisante pour s'adapter à chacune des
situations
nous avons voté une réforme de la
constitution cette réforme de la
constitution nous apporte un outil qui
aurait dû être utilisés qui ne l'est pas
je le déplore
c'est la motion la motion c'est un acte
politique par laquelle une assemblée là
notre assemblée nationale exprime une
conviction forte et laisse à ceux qui
ont la responsabilité au quotidien de
gérer le pays d'en tenir compte dans
l'exercice de leurs responsabilités dans
le soutien de l'état aux entreprises
il y à une infinité de situations voté
une motion de principe pour reconnaître
que le contribuable n'a pas à venir au
secours de dirigeants défaillant est une
motion qui recueillerait l'unanimité de
nous notre assemblée l'unanimité de
l'assemblée nationale
mais lorsque l'on entre dans le détail
de la gestion des entreprises et la
comparaison entre le décret qui vient
d'être adoptée par le gouvernement et
l'amendement de jean arthuis et les
observations de madame briques le prouve
jusqu'où faut-il aller où doit-on
s'arrêter
quels sont les cas de figure qui
méritent d'être reconnus comme
présentant de l'intérêt ou commettantes
anodin c'est justement la distinction
entre une orientation de principe qui
aurait été la motion et la
responsabilité du gouvernement dans
l'adoption de clauses contractuelles de
soutien avec les entreprises privées
refusent d'ailleurs ces entreprises
privées qui aurait permis à l'état
partenaire et d'une certaine façon à
l'état créancier de fixer des règles
adaptées à la situation de l'entreprise
en tenant compte de l'esprit d'émotion
je vous donne deux exemples extrêmement
concret tirés de l'actualité un grand
groupe automobile français vient de
changer de président en pleine crise
décide de changer de président et de
changer rapidement et quand on écoute
les déclarations du président sortant
aux mesures que cette décision ne
recueille pas l'assentiment du président
sortant qui a été surpris par cette
décision
l'actionnaire a donc pris sa
responsabilité cette entreprise
appartient au groupe automobile
on peut imaginer peut-être là je ne sais
pas at elle aidé par l'état
l'at elle demandait l'at elle pas
demandé en tout état de cause lorsque
des actionnaires à travers leur conseil
d'administration pour recruter nouveau
président ils vont naturellement lui
faire des propositions et si l'on veut
un président de qualité il est
vraisemblable que ce président demande à
être associé au succès au retournement
d'entreprises dont il prend la charge
s'il ne réforme pas l'entreprise il ne
bénéficiera de rien s'il retourne
l'entreprise et ce sera une condition au
moment de son de son irruption dans
l'entreprise pour le pôle à la redresser
faudra des conditions doit-on se priver
de la possibilité de renouveler un
dirigeant des dirigeants doit-on traiter
tous les dirigeants du mmm entreprises
de la même façon entre ceux qui gagnent
en productivité qui gagnant par
commercial et ceux qui perdent sur le
terrain financier ce que les autres ont
gagné par la démarche commerciale ou par
la démarche industrielle
je crois qu'il faut laisser à l'état
lorsqu'il intervient comme créanciers
comme n'importe quelle banque est comme
n'importe quel actionnaire la liberté de
fixer ces règles d'attention mais dans
le cadre d'un esprit général qu'une
motion aurait pu fixer
prenons un deuxième cas de figure nous
vous aurez sans doute pour sauver
certaines ans
reprise à accepter à concevoir des
fusions ces fusions vont reposer sur la
valorisation de l'entreprise que vous
aider et qui va être apportée à une
entreprise qui peut la soutenir
il serait quand même tout à fait
étonnant qu'une entreprise extérieure
puisse bénéficier d'une valorisation
dégradée pour pouvoir prendre une part
importante du capital de la société
cible alors que les cadres qui peuvent
participer au redressement de
l'entreprise les cadres nouveaux ou des
cadres qui ont prouvé dans l'entreprise
leurs capacités soient privés de cette
opportunité parce que il y aurait eu
intervention détail application d'une
règle générale je pense en effet mme
labrie que vous avez raison je le dis
très clairement que la course de vitesse
n'a pas permis peut-être d'affronter la
complexité de situation dans laquelle à
aucun moment
l'état doit ou ne doit oublier qu'ils
gèrent l'argent des contribuables n'est
que cet argent la meilleure façon de le
gérer
c'est encore de la porter aux
entreprises en tenant compte de chaque
situation
c'est la raison pour laquelle je mon
cher collègue jean arthuis je ne voterai
pas votre amendement non pas que jean
réprouve l'esprit mais je pense que le
dispositif d'un article de loi pour
encadrer et enfermé l'intervention de
l'état au bénéfice d'entreprises qui
sont beaucoup plus nombreuses et
beaucoup trop rigide et ne permet pas
d'épouser la multiplicité des situations
maintenant pensent que cet amendement
sera votée parce que dans l'émotion
générale il faut en effet condamné ceux
qui ont des feuilles
le drame c'est que beaucoup d entre des
dirigeants d'entreprises n'ont pas
manqué à leur tâche se sont battus dans
un environnement conflictuelle
concurrence y est extraordinairement
difficile et ont dû affronter des
difficultés qu'ils étaient parfaitement
imprévisible
bon ils demandent l'aide de l'état
qu'ils renoncent qu'il suspende jeu tout
le monde l'acceptent mais s'il y a des
opportunités où il faut renouveler des
équipes dirigeantes ou fusionner des
entreprises ne nous privons pas la
possibilité de rechercher les meilleurs
merci au chocolat un plomb explication
autre rapport à nicolas alfonsi
leur collègue très brièvement
je ne dispenserait de considérations
techniques puisqu'elles ont été évoqués
également de considérations subalterne
au moment où le rapporteur général
s'exprimait je me suis tourné vers mon
collègue zocchetto et je lui ai dit
confidentiellement et finira par nous
faire croire que le décret une portée
plus importante que la loi je crois que
quand on tourne quand on tournait ce
soir à 20 heures un bouton de télévision
des entendions le président la
république à londres dire qu'il fallait
faire la guerre au trader supprimer des
stock options et nous nous contenterions
d'un décret décret qui seraient
immédiatement applicables comme si
monsieur le ministre on ne peut pas un
seul instant imaginer qu'à partir du
moment où la loi est votée tout
disparaît nous ne serons plus dans des
problèmes de délais d'application ou de
procédures dont j'ai le sentiment que
j'aurais vraiment petit bras compte tenu
d'un problème qui interpelle la nation
entière
le problème est symbolique il est
politique mais je crois que dans ces
conditions il est important de voter ce
texte regroupe les rats de groupe rdse
s'associera à votre maman
merci mon chèque l'ailier t-il d'autres
explications de vote
je donne la parole à jean arthuis
résident j'ai bien entendu tous les
points de vue qui viennent de s'exprimer
et tout particulièrement le vôtre
monsieur le ministre il s'agit pas ici
d'imaginer je ne sais quelle compétition
de course vitesse entre le gouvernement
et le parlement
je crois que dans ces circonstances il
est important que le parlement fixe la
règle et je salue la promptitude du
gouvernement le décret s'applique
il a des vertus conservatoires
si la loi est votée un autre décret
viendra le compléter le conforter mais
que je sache il n'y aura pas péril en la
demeure et sur leurs proches qui peut
m'être fait de ne pas avoir prévu une
disposition que contient le décret à
savoir que les conventions prévoient que
les éléments variables de la
rémunération ne sont attribuées ou
versée si la situation de l'entreprise
l'a conduit à procéder à des
licenciements de forte ampleur
je vous avoue que j'ai eu un une
tentation mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire forte ampleur donc si si le sénat
vote l'amendement que je vous propose
j'espère bien que d'ici demain
après-midi d'ici la commission mixte
paritaire
nous trouverons une rédaction
satisfaisante au plan formel
enfin monsieur le ministre je voudrais
vous dire que le décret vise le recours
aux émissions d'actions d'actions de
préférence ou de titres super
subordonnés souscrits par la société de
prise de participation de l'état ainsi
que le bénéfice des prêts accordés par
l'état aux constructeurs automobiles il
ya deux constructeurs automobiles et il
ya six groupes bancaires qui ont
bénéficié de de ces apports sous forme
d'émission d'actions d'actions de
préférence ou de titres super
subordonnés
par conséquent le texte que je vous
propose va un peu plus loin puisqu'il
vise des sous traitants il n'y a pas si
longtemps un sous-traitant important du
secteur automobile a défrayé la
chronique du fait du versement
d'indemnités de départ n'étaient pas
visés par ce texte
il est vraisemblable que ce
sous-traitant va bénéficier d'une aide
de l'état
ce soir nous avons voté un amendement
que vous nous avez proposé monsieur le
ministre chant millions pour des
préservant ce dans le cadre de la
réindustrialisation et bien j'ai la
faiblesse de penser que le texte que je
vous propose permettrait pendant que ces
prêts avances ont consenti de veiller à
ce que les règles de bonne gouvernance
sont respectés dans l'entreprise
bénéficiaire de ces fonds voilà c'est
tout cela ça l'est que cela je pense que
le parlement doit assumer ses
prérogatives et il peut le faire en
pleine confiance avec le gouvernement
les circonstances que nous traversons ne
nous dispense pas nous parlementaires
d'exprimer par un vote
ce que nous entendons voir ériger comme
règle en cette matière merci monsieur le
ministre
oui je voudrais monsieur le président
encore une fois 20 indiqué qu' on n'est
pas dans une course entre pouvoirs
réglementaires et pouvoir législatif
j'espère que ce n'est pas ça parce que
la situation est suffisamment grave pour
ne pas entrer dans ce type de débat
le gouvernement a réagi vite il devait
le faire et il l'a fait par le biais du
pouvoir réglementaire comme il l'avait
indiqué là dessus il fallait absolument
le faire et nous l'avons fait
nous l'avons fait de façon appropriée
car on peut toujours chercher à se poser
la question de savoir ce qu'est une
intervention de l'état parce que les
exonérations de charges
ici ou ailleurs dans les zones franches
urbaines etc tout cela ne relève pas de
cela il fallait le préciser le décret
l'a clairement précisé c'est pour ça que
le décret n'est pas un décret
généraliste et un décret d'application
et c'est un décret opérationnelle qui
répond aux questions posées par
l'opinion publique et au fond ce que
vous proposez c'est à la fois une loi
vienne repréciser ce que le décret a
déjà dit et donc nous allons nous
retrouver avec un nouveau décret qui
ressemblera aux des grecs qui a été pris
hier donc on est dans un système
tendance un peu à l'étrange la
différence entre votre texte monsieur
jean arthuis et le texte du gouvernement
tend essentiellement à l'implication et
au rôle du fonds stratégique
d'investissement nous considérons que le
fonds stratégique d'investissement est
un outil tout à fait particulier il
n'est pas là pour répondre aux
difficultés passagères du nantes au
contraire pour investir durablement dans
une entreprise et ce n'est pas du tout
les mêmes choses et notamment pour
entreprendre venir en aide à une
entreprise en période par exemple de de
développement et c'est justement dans
ces entreprises parfois que la politique
de stocks options et parfaitement bien
le vin est une bonne politique c'est
elle elle est même né de cela et
d'ailleurs ce qui a été critiqué c'est
justement qu'elle ait quitté ce champ là
donc on est bien dans un système où
l'intervention par le fonds stratégique
d'investissement ne doit pas être
confondue avec les autres interventions
de l'état
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que dans le
dans le décret la ministre de l'économie
est chargé
la ministre de l'économie et chargé
d'ailleurs le décret dit lamy chargé de
l'économie veille à ce que le fonds
stratégique d'investissement prennent en
compte dans sa politique
d'investissement et dans le cadre de sa
participation à la gouvernance des
sociétés dont les titres sont admis et
cédera donc il ya bien un point
particulier qui est la surveillance des
entreprises qui se font partie et qu'ils
font et qui bénéficient de
l'investissement du fonds stratégique
dans le cadre de leur politique de
rémunération globale donc c'est une
surveillance globale qui portait sur
c'est sur ces entreprises
et c'est bien une règle déontologique
d'orientation et d'investissement du
fonds du fonds stratégique
voilà ce que je voulais dire nous devons
je pense dans cette période là plutôt
que de chercher à s'opposer comme ça les
uns les autres tous deux vont au
contraire
et si plutôt nounou coordonnées ci de
faire en sorte que ce que nous avons à
dire soit dit clairement devant
l'opinion et que penserait au fond
l'opinion d'un débat comme celui là avec
un amendement voté qui conduirait
probablement à rendre plus compliquée la
compréhension dans l'opinion de ce que
fait le pouvoir politique
en face de cela à ben oui puisque nous
avons je n'abuse pas je dis ce que je
pense
j'ai compris que j'ai compris la queue
parti socialiste soutenait l'amendement
de monsieur arthuis qui reprend décret
du gouvernement dont vous êtes d'accord
avec le gouvernement pour la première
fois dans cette crise c'est déjà une
première chose et je m'en félicite vous
soutenez la politique du gouvernement
dans le domaine des rémunérations c'est
ça ce que vous ne venez de nous dire
même aymeric ce n'est pas autre chose
mais je m'en réjouis
tant mieux il est tard nous avons
attendu longtemps pour que ce soit le
cas vous soutenez aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste soutient la politique du
gouvernement dans le domaine du contrôle
des rémunérations
c'est ce que vous dites et si vous votez
cet amendement c'est ce que vous direz à
la population et à la nation mais vous
prenez vos responsabilités
j'ai pas à me mêler des dissensions
aujourd'hui entre les différentes
factions qui composent le parti
socialiste vous expliquerez entre vous
mais c'est ça que vous dirai à la nation
et moi je voudrais véritablement essayé
de dire aux sénateurs mais je remercie
notamment le sénateur de raincourt et
qui à plusieurs reprises venue tant en
explications de ce texte
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un débat
qui au fond est majeur parce qu'en
réalité
nous devons dire à l'opinion publique ce
que nous pensons et nous allons
aujourd'hui crée de la confusion plutôt
que de la clarté et je le regretterai
franchement notamment sur des sujets
aussi délicats et aussi sensible merci
messieurs miss je ne vois pas d'autres
explications de vote
monsieur foucault fait monsieur dominati
puis en ce cheminement vers le vote oui
vous avez raison monsieur le ministre
1 j'ai entendu notamment de la mouche de
notre collègue gérard longuet que
quelque part c'était ce décret et
l'amendement qui va avec la
reconnaissance de l'émotion de la
population
merci puisque nous ne cessons de le dire
mais sachez que nous sommes bien
convaincu que ce décret est là pour
essayer de calmer cette population ces
salariés qui manifestent toujours en
plus grand nombre ces derniers temps
mais simplement de dire que c'est pas
suffisant et que daisy hier d'ailleurs
les organisations syndicales ont dit non
à cela
l'amendement de jean arthuis est pour
nous le calque du décret ne le
partageons pas notre groupe a fait une
proposition de loi portant sur des
questions notamment sur des questions
que nous avons débattu pendant est
encore l'otan de ce collectif budgétaire
à savoir la question des stocks options
la question des rénumérations la
question des parachutes dorés la
question du bouclier fiscal la majorité
sénatoriale et jean arthuis ils ont
refusé et je tenais à le dire mais jean
arthuis ce soir a fait une proposition
dans le code de l'explication de son
amendement
il a notamment proposé que soit amélioré
le texte
j'aurai à lui dire que nous y sommes
favorables
d'ailleurs nous laverons sous-amendé
bernard véra
disais tout à l'heure notamment dans
l'ems par rapport à l'explication sur
son sous-amendement la question de les
listes des licenciements pour nous la
question des licenciements et comme pour
vous je suppose monsieur arthuis c'est
une question fondamentale le
gouvernement a répondu par le thème
grande ampleur je pense que ça veut dire
grande ampleur c'est si ces fermetures d
entreprises si ces 106 et 206 et 300 en
ce qui nous concerne la question des
licenciements doit être liées justement
à cette discussion que nous souhaitons
avoir avec les uns et des autres pour en
finir justement que lorsque l'état
apporte des moyens aux entreprises
publiques notamment dans le cadre de
pessah ou dans le code de renault qui
soit hors de question de licencier comme
d'ailleurs il est hors de question de
licencier dans les autres entreprises
voilà donc on tendait la main par
rapport à une discussion progressistes
dans le cas de l'amélioration du sort
des salariés notamment des entreprises
précitées
et puis comme le disait justement nicole
bricq
je vais faire court puisque nous voulons
pas être des godillots être géré par des
décrets et la france n'ont plus les
syndicalistes l'ont dit hier nous
pensons que le gouvernement doit
légiférer sinon nous n'aurions pas fait
fait cette proposition de loi qui a été
discuté ici la semaine prochaine et la
semaine dernière par contre et c'est
donc pour cela que nous voterons
l'amendement de jean arthuis nous ont
expliqués sur notre parole et philippe
deux minutes
je crois que c'est une erreur le
président michel venus comme vous nous
avez un site est à dire la vérité et ce
qu'on avait sur le coeur je voudrais
tout d'abord dire que
comme tous les orateurs ce soir je suis
choqué par l'attitude d'un certain
nombre de d'éthique et de dirigeants qui
nous ont amenés qui ont amené le pouvoir
politique à réagir et à répondre à
l'opinion
pour autant je constate que l'état et
les pouvoirs publics sont une fois de
plus affaiblie dans ce genre de débat
lorsque ça a trait au monde de
l'entreprise
sans doute parce que l'état n'est pas un
actionnaire assez puissant sans doute
parce que lorsqu'ils prêtent de l'argent
alors qu'un banquier d'une succursale
pour n'importe quelle pme est capable
d'imposer des conditions dans un
dialogue économique l'état lorsqu'il
prête des milliards il a besoin d'un
décret puis d'une loi pour renforcer les
représentants pour moi c'est un petit
peu surnaturel
ça démontre l'absence de raison dans les
relations entre l'état et l'entreprise
et cela du tout lui dure depuis des
années dans notre pays on a vu des
administrateurs de l'état au sein de
grandes entreprises publiques qui ne
comptait pas ou qui comptait pour beurre
et j'ai l'impression que les leçons du
passé n'ont pas servi
et là où décret on veut superposer la
loi et après je ne sais pas on ira
beaucoup plus loin
et pendant ce temps là gérard longuet
l'a très bien démontré chaque entreprise
est un cas particulier et le mécanisme
eux-mêmes et plus surprenant parce que
plus lente reprise est faible plus on
devrait associer l'équipe dirigeante à
rechercher des solutions à en sortir
autrement dit les entreprises qui vont
bien on ne pose pas le problème de la
rémunération des dirigeants des stock
options et des retraites des parachutes
etc
par contre les entreprises qui sont en
difficulté on va mettre des barrières et
l'exemple d'un changement de dirigeant
en période de crise effectivement c'est
à ce moment là qu'on établit le contrat
de travail et l'état encore une fois
vasselle faiblir alors comme vous nous
incite également à réfléchir je sais que
c'est une heure tardive et qu'on a passé
depuis quelques heures la date du 1er
avril
moi j'aimerais qu'on étende cette
réflexion rémunération je dirais de la
part active du secteur public politique
haute administration
il ya certains pays en cette période de
crise
l'irlande la lituanie où on va réduire
les rémunérations des fonctionnaires
alors c'est pas du tout mon but ce soir
mon but c'est de parler des dirigeants
et des dirigeants du secteur public et
je reconnais que par moments je suis pas
convaincu le rapporteur général du
budget l'a dit on est en période de
crise période exceptionnelle alors
pourquoi lorsqu'on crée des organismes
nouveaux on est obligés d'intégrer les
salaires sur le fonctionnement anciens
pour justifier la rémunération de ces
organismes
c'est choquant ça me convient pas
surtout lorsque ces organismes sont
appelés à régir les tic des entreprises
privées
c'est quelque chose que je n'arrive pas
à comprendre pourquoi et l'a peut-être
monsieur foca de sera exonérée en tant
que ministre des finances mais pourquoi
les ministres des finances les
présidents des commissions des finances
le rapporteur général du budget les
parlementaires ne sont pas indexés sur
leur rémunération
lorsqu'ils votent un budget en déficit
lorsqu'on à moins de 3% de déficit du
pib
pourquoi ne fait-on pas la même chose on
pourrait étendre à l'infini vous voyez
ce genre de discussions je voulais
simplement eu vous le signaler et
l'agacement des chefs d'entreprise est
important c'est vrai il ya des excès les
excès ils sont condamnables je suis
choquée comme tout le monde de ses excès
mais je suis agacé de la tournure des
débats depuis des semaines alors que
nous présentons main collectif
budgétaire avec 100 milliards 104
milliards de déficit et pendant ce temps
là on continue à parler de rémunérations
excessives des dirigeants bien je ne
vois plus expliqué sur le voeu que je
vais mettre aux voix d'abord le
sous-amendement numéro 110 qui a été
posée par monsieur verra qui et pour qui
comprend sous-amendement n'est pas
adoptée même vote sur le sous-amendement
sens même vote
je suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public sur l'amendement 74 rectifié bis
l article 11
il va donc être procédé au squat à fuir
une condition fixée par l'article 46 du
règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
retranscrire un bulletin blanc ce qui
souhaitent voter contre
une teinte bleue ceux qui souhaitent
soutenir un bulletin rouge le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
nombre de votants 339 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 337 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés 170 pour
l'adoption 182 contre 155 le sénat a
adopté pouviez de suivre le vote de
l'amendement déposé par le président de
la commission des finances jean arthuis
un amendement très proche du décret
promulgué lundi par le gouvernement qui
a donc pour objectif d'encadrer les
rémunérations des dirigeants
d'entreprises aidées par l'état je vous
rappelle que le projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour 2009 a été
voté hier par les sénateurs
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt sur public sénat